hi my name is Kat I've been a nurse for
four years hi my name is Courtney I've
been a nurse for four years hi my name
is Donnie I've been a nurse for 14 years
hi I'm Michele Stevenson I've been a
nurse for nine years and today we're
gonna play never have I ever never have
I ever moved the patient to later down
the waitlist because they were rude oh I
haven't made them wait but I'll tell the
doctor like hey can you see them last so
that wasn't necessarily making them wait
it was just like the doctor doing me a
favor I work in the ER and we have you
know in the beginning it's called triage
that's where you check in often times
there's always a wait but it always
helps to be nice it doesn't help to be
rude I'm gonna help the person that's
gonna be nicer versus the person that's
gonna be rude if you're nice and funny
oh my god I will treat you with kisses
and like maybe a sponge bath like I
don't know never have I ever gone on a
date with a patient
oh I have not I'm single so if I see
like this anyone in there 30 is male and
you're like okay are they gonna be hot
it's there in the ER they're never it's
not an appropriate time to be like hey
are you single oh you're here for
diarrhea but I wanted to I used to work
in prison and um I got hit on a lot but
it's a relationship that in I don't
recommend dating your patients
especially if they're inmates I feel
like it's bad when grant like the
elderly patients are like how old are
you
are you married yeah you know like I
have a great grandson that's perfect for
it never have I ever laughed at a
patient I've never like laughed at a
patient it's more like something happens
and then you leave the
and you're like oh my god like I've had
a patient fart like while I'm trying to
do a rectal exam I think that's a really
bad thing but I have left with them okay
I one time the patient was getting ready
for a surgery he have charcoal foot
you've seen that right mmm and the other
nurse asked him like oh do you know why
you're in here and he goes you
hysterectomy and the whole all the
nurses started laughing so hard he was
just being with the nurses never have I
ever had friends ask me for medical
advice all the time every single time
that's been normal yeah and I think it's
also because I work in the ER so it's
like oh she knows everything and it's
like hey I have this weird like bruise
or my kid has a fever and then I've had
friends too with babies and they're like
try asking me things I'm like you know I
don't work on an like NICU a neonatal I
don't work on pediatrics like I work on
elderly adults like I don't know
anything about children cuz I haven't
had any yet I don't really mind once we
get to topical do I have hemorrhoids I'm
like oh I'm also a comedian so like I
have poor comedians send me pictures of
like rashes that are like seven inches
away from there and in what place hey
bro of not a dermatologist but that [ __ ]
looks inflamed never have I ever thrown
up at work I have to I was at work and
somebody got gassed gassed is um when
you mix urine and feces and scrapings
from metal bars and throw it somebody's
face yeah I guess what happens when you
mix urine and feces together and make
metal scraping so what's the first thing
you do you try to get it off yep Apple
in there said to me hey bro I once had a
patient that came in with osteomyelitis
okay diabetes horrible vascular systems
and he had
maggots oh my gosh and I said scuse me I
have to go and all my breakfast came up
never have I ever napped on the job yeah
the night shift for our for our break
time our lunch time is not really for
eating it's for not being nothing yeah
for us it's 8 p.m. to 8:00 in the
morning so like 2 to 4 is that weird
like joining coffee
like now I'm gonna take a little bit
here it was my second night shift and I
did it for 10 minutes and someone woke
me up like it was meant to mention unit
okay yeah I worked at like a old people
Jewish home and like you can't sleep
here and I was like all right behind
never have I ever slept through a shift
not through now I cannot say no nope I
think that'd be impossibly kind of hard
cuz the nurses work 12 hours yeah you
gotta be real tired or hungover
Oh hungover yeah that's not ever good
never have I ever had a patient pretend
to be sick when they actually are not
here people come up they're like I'm
having chest pain and you're like okay
let's you know and you have a line of
people there are people that are like
looking at everybody like oh my gosh if
you take care of that person because
then you would look like the bad person
I think it's also because I've never
worked at ER but like on discharge
doctors like you're good everything's
checked out and they're like well now I
just don't feel good like I don't feel
well oh yeah they're like what's going
on
give me a symptom what's hurting I don't
know it's everything yeah everything
you're like okay I get it no one wants
to wait but you don't have to
about what you're feeling because it
just makes you look bad it's always the
elderly patients that are like I have a
headache and I'm like really because we
did a CT the brain last night it doesn't
look like anything you look great and
you like a headache you can go home with
that yeah we all take it high-lows
you can go to the nursing home listen
never have I ever ignored a call like on
purpose to every time what are you I
plead the fifth but it's those patients
that call and I don't think anyone else
realizes is like they call every two
minutes five literally like on the call
light on the call light on the call
light and you're it it's like okay I was
just in there I just walked out of the
room like I have other patients there's
no way they need something I'll peep in
for the most part i peep in how can I
help you if it's you know you're busy
because sometimes it's silly things like
kinda strong okay like a get strong they
think it's like room service that's what
they see it as like you're my personal
slave for the day and there it's like no
no I'm really actually heard to do a
bunch of other things here's my
political in her politically correct
answer
I have never I have never ignore the
call life but that have prioritized it
I think Nursing in general is such a
rewarding job that you know no matter
what happens you're always gonna be
nurturing and giving and you're gonna
want to help
some days are definitely harder than
others there are definitely patients
that are easier to work with and more
difficult to work with I think the best
thing is like honestly treat your nurses
with respect we're doing our jobs and
yes you know we deal with a lot so
honestly just treat us nicely
we will be the literally the nicest
people back to you for future nurses I
hope we didn't scare you nursing is a
very rewarding profession it's a great
job to have
[Music]